>>Is there anybody who might be
squeamish about touching fish?
>>My name is Michelle Underwood,
I'm a seventh grade teacher
at North Whitfield Middle School,
and I've been teaching
for about 11 years.
>>Student: This one is huge, dude.
>>Michelle: When I started teaching,
I really had a zeal for teaching.
I would come up with creative ideas.
They were kind of snuffed out.
>>Anybody want gloves?
>>As time passed, I conformed,
and did what I was supposed
to, like a good teacher.
I used my textbook, I incorporated
PowerPoint, but it was really death
by PowerPoint for my students.
When I moved here to North
Whitfield, things changed.
>>You need to wash him off
because he's too slimy right now.
>>The first day I walked into North
Whitfield, I was in my suit and heels
and pantyhose, and I looked
around, and I was the only one
in suit and heels and pantyhose.
As one of the other teachers said,
I had to go get some britches.
>>You have a dichotomous key in
front of you, and without shouting
out the answer, I want you
to identify the species
of fish that you have.
>>Andrea: She's very,
very intelligent.
She had her presentations down,
and was extremely structured.
She would stand up in the front,
and expect to give these
elaborate lectures,
and have these adolescents
write down everything she said.
And I was very honest with her
about, if things don't change,
it's not probably going
to work out for you here.
>>Michelle: I went to one of
the education advisors, I guess,
for the school, and just,
honestly, I broke down in tears,
and said, what can I do different?
>>Andrea: She started a book study,
started having collegial
conversations,
and it ended up like a transformation
that I've never seen before.
>>Michelle: We talked about
going into cell organs.
>>Instead of just death
by PowerPoint,
I started incorporating
things like cell phones
and cameras, and video recording.
I'm on the floor, I'm painting,
I've got animals in my room.
My relationship with my students
now is completely different.
Although there's a lot more work
that's put into the actual design
of the lesson, when you
get into your classroom,
and you're in with your
students, you're playing
with your students,
you're having fun.
You're enjoying what you're doing.
>>You're actually seeing
the text upside down.
>>Dennis: In my past, we've
done a lot of textbook work.
I think I like this a lot better.
>>Michelle: I think, when you
see the light in your students,
and they're smiling and they're
having a good time in your class,
and they're learning the standards, I
think that any teacher who sees that
and experiences that,
would change their opinion
of project based learning
versus PowerPoint and textbooks.
>>Student: That's our best one.